[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لا يوجد الفرنسيون فقط
المسيحيون في جميع أنحاء العالم يريدون
الحقيقة سيدتنا تقاوم ثمانمائة
خمسين عاما لماذا سيكون هناك
النار والنار سيدتنا وكما أ
علامة كتحذير جيد من أ
الوضع الدراماتيكي للكل
الكاثوليكية في فرنسا و
المجتمع الفرنسي
الجميع لا يزال 18 هي
انزلق لكنك تحب insee
لا تتوقع ترحيبًا كإلهام
يوم مجنون نعم هذا كل شيء
ondam في نسختين أخريين
الكثير من التخمينات كل حريق
للتظاهر بأنه كان
حادثة
مثل كل الفرنسيين الذين وجدتهم
هذا الترسيب لهذه الأطروحة
سأكون دائمًا هناك دائمًا
كان من المفترض أن أعمل لكني لم أفعل
العمل قبل الأسبوع المقدس
وكان كثيرًا وكان علينا الاختيار
يوم واحد من الجرح وكان هذا
ذلك اليوم
[موسيقى]
عندما دق الإنذار في منطقتنا
لذلك كانت السيدة في منتصف الطريق
احتفال وقيل لنا أولا
مرة
عليك أن تخرج هناك حريق لا يوجد
تدريب في الكاتدرائية
وهذا يعني مرات عندما كنا
يطلق إنذار
أنا فقط اعتقدت أنه كان
عطل الإشارة
منزعج
شخص ترك طرد
خرج الجميع بهدوء
نقول لأنفسنا أننا سنعود بعد عشرة
الدقائق
بعد عشرين دقيقة قيل لنا لك
يمكن أن يعود وفي ذلك الوقت
قال لي القس أنه سينتهي
الاحتفال بالقداس ، أي بدونه
موسيقى
لقد أخبرني للتو أنني أستطيع
بالعودة إلى المنزل وفعلت ذلك
كانت حوالي الساعة 6:45 مساءً.
وبعد ذلك تستمر الكتلة وفي هذه اللحظة
من التكريس في تلك اللحظة نقول
عليك حقا أن تذهب هناك
10 أمتار على السطح ونحن
في الداخل لم يكن هناك شيء لنا
لا نسمع شيئًا لا نرى شيئًا
لم نشعر بشيء
بعد بضع دقائق من زميل
لذلك اتصل بي عازف الأرغن بي
يسأل عما إذا كنت على علم
ماذا كان يحدث أثناء الحديث معها
على الهاتف من نافذة المنزل
رأيت سحابة ضخمة من الدخان
نرى الصور ولكن في
نقول لأنفسنا أن الأمر مختلف
قصة سيدة الذعر من
هذه الكلمات تصعد في دخان الاطار
أنا معتاد على الذهاب إلى هناك لزيارة ولكن
غالبًا ما تذهب إلى المنزلقات بعد أن كان
السيطرة على الأشياء عندما أقود من
إطار نجار لمسته
أنا أسير هكذا تتبع الخشب
شعرنا
قصة شعرت بعاطفة
حول و هناك عندما أصل
بضع مئات من الأمتار أستطيع رؤيتها
السقف الذي يقع بالكامل تحت
النيران
[موسيقى]
في وقت ما تتحول الريح
شبكة السهم ولكني أسمع
[موسيقى]
كان حقًا بجانب السرير
شخص يموت وأنا أقول لنفسي نعم
كل شيء يسير هو تدمير tuv
[موسيقى]
بصراحة حول نهاية العالم
في اليوم التالي في وقت مبكر جدًا من الصباح كنت
المشي على أرصفة نهر السين و
رأيت الكثير من الباريسيين الذين رأيتهم
يجتمع على وجه الخصوص خياط
حجر سيدتنا التي عملت
لمدة 50 عامًا في هذه الكاتدرائية و
من قال لي يا سيدي هل لديك
خطاب طرح السؤال لمعرفة ماذا
هذا لأنني لا أرى كيف
كان من الممكن أن يحترق هكذا وهذا ما
عندما رأيت إيفاد وكالة فرانس برس
أيضا حيث المدعي العام
قال شيئًا رائعًا
قال أولاً أن القديم سيكون
قال لفترة طويلة وفي نفس الجملة
نحن على يقين من أنه واحد فقط
حادثة
الغرفة تناديني بالمصائب الصغيرة
وفقط 3
بوسيج
lahoud أدليت بياني الذي
فضائحه التي كانت واحدة فقط
لدي دائمًا سؤال وأريد أن أعرف ما إذا كان
إنه حادث
عمل خبيث أو جريء و
بعد هذا الخطاب من قبل الجميع
السلطات السياسية
أطلقوا ضدي الصحفيين في
قائلا انني متآمر
لقد كان من العار ما فعلته للتو
ليقول
وهذا رد الفعل الذي لا يطاق
السلطات
تدليك يقول أنني وضعت إصبعي على
مشكلة الأذينين من قبل المعادين أو
قاتلة في راديوشاك ونحن نتخيل
بدلا من ذلك عندما أخذت وقتا طويلا
عرض كبير
إيف جزيرة المدينة لديها دائما
المشكلة ، وهذا يعني أنه في الواقع هو كذلك
جزيرة
حيث توجد حياة قليلة جدًا خارج
الحياة السياحية وهذا كل شيء ومرة
الكاتدرائية التي كانت نوعا ما القوة الدافعة
وكان عمود هذه المجموعة واقفا
اعتقل في 15 أبريل / نيسان مساء الماضي
لم يعد هناك أي حياة اقتصادية في الواقع
في هذه الجزيرة ، لذلك عليك أن تجد ملف
ديناميكية جديدة لا يوجد فعل
نرحب بالسيرة الذاتية للسائحين لتنغمس فيها
انها ليست اثنين
ليس هناك مكان لوضع الخاص بك
الأمتعة وهو أمر مؤسف إذا لم نفعل ذلك
لا شيء يستوعبه على أفضل وجه
الملايين والملايين من الناس الذين
يأتون من جميع أنحاء العالم لمشاهدة
دام وباريس توماس ، إنها المعركة
السياسة التي أتابعها مع الكثيرين
الآخرين حتى أن الحبار لدينا
يتم إعادة بناء الرجال بشكل متماثل
إنها معركة من أجل الحقيقة
تاريخي
إنها معركة حيث يتم احترام القواعد
من esu هو عقد قتالي
السياحة رئيس غير ناضجة
كل ما لدي ديل تونالي لابنتنا
نوتردام أكتوبر قد سقط سوف يبدو
داتي فيناتير مدينة بينليا ميدون
اختياري وتزوج فيلم البينا
هندي منذ أن صوتت ضد
الجمعية الوطنية
لقد حاربت هذا القانون لماذا بسبب
أنه إذا كان من الطبيعي تسريع
إعادة الإعمار وتحسين
تنسيق القوات ل
إعادة بناء نوتردام
أنا لا أرى اسم ما نحن مدينون به
فصل المهندسين المعماريين من الآثار أو
في قصب التنبيه ووقت الهواء
يفرح لامين بارا ملف مماثل
إلى المعدلات الوطنية يقوض الشباب أ
خدع تيمون السهم أخيرًا
هل أنت ذاهب إلى اللعنة
لإعادة بناء متطابقة سوف تجد
إجاباتهم
بدأت التغذية بحكمة بالفعل
وأوضح عدة مرات جعلتها
الطريقة الخام التي تغلق فمها أن
لدينا خياره لسيدة لدينا
باريس عندما احترقت الكاتدرائية
ثم في الايام التي شقت منه
الصورة الأولى التي تصل و
الحجر بعد أن كان هناك الكثير من هؤلاء
مقترحات غير مرغوب فيها من البعض
المهندسين المعماريين الذين أطلقوا العنان لهم
خيالهم وصنعها
اقتراحات
رأيت المشاريع سترسل أ
نوع من البركة على السطح
سيدتنا هو ببساطة
مستحيل لأن حوض السباحة
وزن الماء ثقيل جدا و
من الواضح أن الكاتدرائية لن تدعم
ليس هذا الوزن كما رأيت الأنواع
تزلج المسار لا معنى له
كما رأيت الغابات
إنه على قمة الكاتدرائية
لا تعرف من أين جذور الشجرة أو أ
زنبق هذا tf1 الأبيض لا يمكنه صنع سقف
زجاج على نوتردام
لأننا لن نكون قادرين على الحفاظ على
الرعاية حتى الآن لم يكن هناك
دعوة لتقديم عطاءات على إعادة إعمار
نوتردام باريس
رجل الروح على نداء المرحلة الخطرة
شكرا لحالة الطوارئ أو الدولة ل
حفظ المبنى الآن هم
لا يزال يهدد هؤلاء الأزواج و
الكاتدرائية بنيت ل
تستوعب إطار خشبي و
سقف
يأخذ وزنا معينا من
مبدأ أنك أ
كاتدرائية
نحن نتكئ على رأسك تصل
لعقد هكذا دون أي مشكلة
لمدة ثمانمائة وخمسين سنة لك
إزالة اليد اليمنى
بطبيعة الحال سوف ترتفع في الواقع
لذلك أنت بحاجة إلى وزن معين
أنه ثقيل جدًا لا يجب سحقه
يجب ألا يكون الهيكل
خفيف جدًا بحيث لا يتسلق بدقة
نحن نضع
الشماعات هياكل خشبية تحتها
دعامات الأرضيات في
في الواقع على رأس
الكاتدرائية إلى حد ما لتحل محل
وزن الإطار لأن
المبدأ هو الضغط باستمرار
على النصب
والشيء الملح أيضًا هو
في الواقع تفكيك السقالات
مكان لاستعادة السهم
الكاستيلان
ها هو ومن خلال تفكيكه عليك القيام به
كن حذرا لأنه يبقينا
يسأل إن لم يكن يحافظ أيضًا على
كاتدرائية الذوق هو الوقت
لن يتم تفكيك السقالات
لا يمكن أن تبدأ العمل
[موسيقى]
لقد بدأت في نوتردام في نهاية
الحساب كانت وظيفة صيفية الأمر متروك لها
يقول وظيفة طالب وكان هناك
مكان في استقبال الكاتدرائية
ثم عُرض عليّ القدوم إلى العمل
في المكاتب لأنني فعلت
كل نفس الدراسات التي سمحت لي
أيضا للقيام بأعمال السكرتارية
حلمت أن التكلفة جاءت من 18 عامًا
كنت بصحبة الكاتدرائية
مع 18 أو صغير جدًا
ثم اليوم الذي ظهر فيه ملف
المنصب الذي أصبح متاحًا تقدم بطلب
لان
[موسيقى]
سيكون من الرائع العمل
هناك أيضا
بالإضافة إلى بقائنا كنا معًا من
فجأة أصبحت قريبًا من السياح
يساهم في عدم تنظيم
المكتب ولكن الوظيفة فوق كل شيء
كان من المشرفين
[موسيقى]
لم أصدق أنني كنت جدا
حزين
[موسيقى]
كان لدي هذا المرفق لسيدة لدينا
الذي كان لا يزال مهمًا للغاية
حقيقة أن زوجي يأتي للعمل
أيضا إلى سيدتنا وقد فهم هذا
حاجز
لذا فهي قصة عائلية
إنها نوع من الأسرة ثم سنعنا
تزوج نفسي منذ هذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
وكل ذلك
السفر ولدت في باري ولدت
في باريس كنا نعيش في حي
كان بجوار منزلنا كان هناك
كان لدي دائما انطباع بأن الجزيرة
كانت المدينة سفينة كبيرة أ
قارب كبير مع موقف في الوسط
قيادة من كانت سيدة
ثم هذا البرجين اللذين
كانت مثل منارتين ساطعتين
في المقدمة كانت فرحة أن أصبح كاهنًا
في نوتردام دي باريس ثم في
أن أقول إن كتلي الأولى هي الآلة
الذي هو فوقنا و
أول آلة سمعتها
وفي قروض الشباب
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي
لقد وقعت في حب هذا
صك قررت نفسي
العب بمنصب السلاح العظيم الأول
أعتقد أنه يمكننا القول أنه كذلك
أشهر الأورغن في العالم
في المجموع الآن خمسة عشر عامًا
أنا في غيانا شرق قلبنا
سيدة هو علاوة على ذلك نتلقى جدا
عازفو الأرغن بانتظام من جميع أنحاء العالم
الذين يقومون بالرحلة في بعض الأحيان
فقط ضعوا أصابعهم على هذا
أداة
عند الحريق في نوتردام
أصيبت الأسرة بأكملها بالندوب بسبب
أطفالنا أيضا لهم سيدتنا
سي سي سي شخص سادس في منطقتنا
الأسرة
عندما علمت أن مرضه يقتل
عميق أو ملمس أو ممتلئ مثل
اكتشفت معظم النساء
مرض لأنني كنت كبيرة
ساعة إذا وصلوا صباح اليوم
الكاتدرائية وأنا أضع نفسي في مستوى
المرمى
[موسيقى]
أهمية إتيان أو يأتي منه
عمود
وقضيت وقتي في التأمل
اميلي محترمة أمس في الصباح
كل صباح وطرد كل
في الصباح وعند قدميه
سمعتنا سيدتنا العذراء نحن
سمعت وشكرا لها
أنهم لم يصلوا
أشياء جميلة للجميع في نهاية
الحساب
لا يمكن أن عبرت
الكثير من الوقت وهذا في ليلة واحدة
دمر تقريبا
عشت لمدة أربعة أشهر ونصف في
بجانبها مثل الهيكل العظمي
رأيت أن الزجاج المعشق قد أزيل
لقد فضحناه أزلنا
أزلنا الحجارة أنا
رأى كل تلك الأشياء التي تم ترقيمها
مرقمة وكل هذا كأننا
كان يجري تشريح الجثة
لمعرفة من أشعل النار كيف
لقد ذهب
لدينا بعض الآنا فارس لا لوار لا
كنيسة القديس سولبيس الكبرى في باريس أ
تمت مهاجمته أمام
باب نار تحدثنا عنه
لذلك فمن الواضح أنه عند 110 من
تكشفت سيدة على خلفية
يتم الدفاع عن المسيحية من قبل المتطرفين
في فرنسا
جزء من العنصريين يريد تماما
أن هناك تصادم بين
المسيحية والإسلام
يرفضون فكرة أننا نستطيع العيش
معا كل ما يمكن أن يطعم
أفكارهم كل ما يمكن القيام به
يؤمنون بما يوجد فيه المسلمون
فرنسا أين وفي أوروبا تسبب في
مصيبة القارة حسنا فهم لا يهتمون
سيتم استخدامها لتطوير الأطروحات و
من الواضح أن هناك إشاعات من هذا القبيل
كان لهجمات
كل مسلم يعرف ذلك
منذ نفس هؤلاء الإرهابيين 1 الذين
ادعى
يقول هذا يسأل الإسلام لا يبالي
لا يخفي ولكن هنا بشكل صارم
لا يوجد دليل على أنه ليس لديه ذلك
سيدتنا التي عرفت هذه النار
لا يوجد رد فعل رسمي أو
عمليا ليس الأول في فرنسا نحن
ليس لديه الحق وليس الحق في
وسائل الإعلام للحديث عن تدنيس
النوبات
كان هناك أكثر من 1000 ألف فعل
ضد المسيح أي 3 المال في
بلدنا ونحن لا نتحدث عنه أو إذا
لديك عمل ضد مسجد في
المنسق synaeghel نتحدث عنه وهو
سينما نوتردام العادية
انتهيت من القول إنه مغناطيسي
قال روسي إنه جرافسمان كلف
أيضا للحفاظ على عادل الفاضلي
قوانين
رسل سيدتنا لم يسبق لها مثيل
تم ترميم هذه التماثيل حتى الآن
مصنوعة أساسًا من النحاس لـ
الجلد والهيكل الداخلي في
الصلب وقت التمثال
ماء لا يوجد تآكل
ولكن بمجرد وجود مشكلة
بدأ اختراق المياه
تتدهور
أهم سبب ل
ترميم هذا العمل
إنه الهيكل الداخلي الموجود فيه
والصدأ البالي لدينا
فك القطع التي عقدت
تمثال ثم علينا لحام الرؤوس
لإزالة الرؤوس التي سمحت
لتمرير نظام الرفع لدينا أ
حزام داخل التمثال ل
مصاعد الطاقة لأخذها
الإطار في الأشرطة لتكون قادرة على
جمع العملات المعدنية ويقرر مع
رافعة يزيد ارتفاعها عن 50 مترا و
النزول في شاحنة ل
احضر هنا
لكن هذه الفرائض لها جدا
هشة نراها هنا
نرى المرونة حتى لو كان لدينا
تشديد القوانين مثل تلك التي نود أن نحصل عليها
سحقت لهذا السبب مررنا
في الداخل لرفعهم وهو لديه
اضطررت إلى تفكيك الرأس لتتمكن من ذلك
حقًا الوصول إلى الأماكن الموجودة
مقاومة مع اللون الأصلي الذي
هل هذه عجلتي كم نحن محظوظون
يقوم الاتحاد الأوروبي بإيداع قوانينه
أربعة أيام قبل هذا الحريق الرهيب
[موسيقى]
آن والعريس لركوب
حسنا لدينا
هذا جيد
[موسيقى]
أوه
م
[موسيقى]
و
كنا مصابين بكدمات شديدة
كما أعتقد كل الفرنسيين
عمليا في
هذه النار التي دمرتها أجمل
المعالم الأثرية في باريس
كنا
مزق حقا ثم نحن
كان أيضًا ضيقًا جدًا في ملعب صيفي
نقلت على موجات الأثير لوسائل الإعلام
الفرنسية والأغنية التي سخر منها
نار رجالنا الذين يريدون أن يكونوا
روح الدعابة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حرية التعبير التي تجعل الباندا
نحن على حق في التجديف في فرنسا
يقول أن حرية التعبير
حقيقة أنه يمكننا أيضًا أن نسخر منها
ديانات أخرى
ولكن في الواقع إذا سعينا وراء
اليهودية
حتى لو هاجمنا الإسلام هناك
صرخة مما يعني أن كل من
ثم يتوقف
بينما عندما يتعلق الأمر ب
المسيحية في فرنسا يمكننا الذهاب إلى هناك
يمكنك صب السيول من الطين و
والتي لا يوجد منها أو لا توجد عمليا
رد فعل الحكومة
[موسيقى]
ولدت في المغرب
أتذكر هناك لعبة 3 3 سنوات بعد ذلك و
لقد أمضيت حياتي كلها في فرنسا
بلا حدود أدخل أ
كنيس أو كاتدرائية لك
موسكو السنوية تلعب هناك فيما بينهم
كل ما هو جيد
الكاتدرائية لا فرق
من ديانات بعضهم البعض
كان الباب مفتوحا للجميع
لذلك فهي الكنيسة الوطنية حقًا
أو إذا جاز لي القول إنني ثروة
كل عشاق الفن
من هم أفكر في
العمارة النحتية
الموسيقى
اليوم عندما أذهب من إلى
الفراغات التنبيه
أنا غير سعيد للغاية هناك
لا شيء أكثر من مجرد هيكل عظمي اليوم
اليوم التالي
المكان الذي ذهبت فيه للصلاة
لذا استقراري هو المكان الذي كنت أذهب إليه
أقول قداس حتى حياتي المكان الذي أنا فيه
كان يقوم بعملي استقبال الترحيب
يتكلم المعترف به في جميع اللغات
وانتهى الأمر أثر فينا
في أعماق أنفسنا لأنه كان كذلك
كاتدرائيتنا
في ذيل
بعد الأسباب في الواقع
كما قال زوجي فقط الرب
و
وكان أصدقاء نوتردام دي باريس
خلقت بالفعل قبل الحريق
لأن الكاتدرائية كانت موجودة بالفعل
حالة سيئة للغاية
لذلك من الواضح أن العمل الذي يتعين القيام به
الآن أكثر عملاقًا
فيما يتم جمعه بالفعل
اليوم
لا تحسب بالطبع الوعود
التبرعات وما إلى ذلك.
من المحتمل أن يكون حوالي 10٪ من
ما هو مطلوب
مرحلة تأمين
تكاليف هذه المرحلة الأولى
بالفعل حوالي 100 مليون
رغبة رئيس الوزراء في أن يكون
أطلقت هذه المسابقة المعمارية
ربما سيختار واحدة جديدة
المشروع الذي سيختاره لاستعادة
السهم المتطابق اعتقد الاخير
سيأتي ميومو على أي حال الرئيس
للجمهورية
لي ماذا يمكنني أن أقول لك
درس المبنى عن كثب
صحيح أن هذا المبنى كان في حالة سيئة
اذكر ذلك إذا أردنا ذلك
يختفي المبنى الذي كنا نتوقعه
سنوات قليلة قد رفضت هذا
الرعاية التي قمنا بها وهنا و
بناء وبالتالي اختفى بشكل طبيعي
لهذا السبب أنا شخصيا
لا تؤمن بنظرية أنه سيكون
شخص سئ النية ل
أسباب تجارية أخرى وتدميرها
أعتقد أنه حادث
كما يحدث كل يوم
اوكسجين كريم حاج ام لا في الخريف
إنه اليوم لا أستبعد أي شيء
الإصدار نحن معطلة أنا
أنا رجل هادئ أطلب مثل
عضو الأمة
رئيس حزب سياسي
التحقيق الذي يقول الحقيقة
[موسيقى]
هناك معارضة قوية حقًا
الموجود بين المشاريع
حكومية
ومنذ الشعب الفرنسي الكاثوليكي
من يريد إعادة بناء متطابقة
إعادة الإعمار بحيث الكاتدرائية
لا تزال الكاتدرائية
[موسيقى]